MY SHOW.
[LAUGHTER]
ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU, SENATOR .
PRESIDENT TRUMP HIGHLIGHTED THE
AMERICAN MEN AND WOMEN WHO ARE
WORKING TO KEEP THIS COUNTRY
RUNNING DURING THIS PANDEMIC.
HERE’S WHAT HE SAID.
>> WE ARE TAKING AGGRESSIVE
ACTION NOW AS ONE NATION AND ONE
FAMILY SO THAT AMERICA CAN
REBOUND STRONGER PEERED FRANKLY,
STRONGER THAN EVER BEFORE.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT WHILE MANY
AMERICAN WORKERS CAN WORK FROM
HOME, MANY OTHERS CANNOT.
MANY OF OUR HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS, FIRST RESPONDERS, AND
MANY IN THE FOOD SERVICE AND
MANUFACTURING, ARE SHOWING UP
AND STANDING UP TO PROVIDE US
WITH THE GOODS AND SERVICES WE
NEED.
>> AND JOINING US NOW IS THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, ALSO HEADING UP
TO PRESIDENT’S TASK FORCE ON
CORONA.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH A
SPIRIT TO GO THANK YOU, SEAN.
>> Sean: LET’S START, WE’VE
GOT A LOT OF GROUND TO COVER.
A LOT OF THINGS HAVE BEEN
HAPPENING.
THIS 15 DAYS OF GUIDELINES TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THE
REASON FOR THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS.
>> WELCOME SEAN, FIRST,
THANK YOU FOR YOUR EFFORTS TO
CONVEY THE PRESIDENT’S
CORONAVIRUS GUIDELINES FOR
AMERICAN.
THE PRESIDENT UNVEILED YESTERDAY
AND WHAT WE ARE PLEASED TO LEARN
IS BEING EMBRACED BY STATES AND
COMMUNITIES AND MILLIONS OF
AMERICAN FAMILIES OF WHAT WE
BELIEVE IS IMPORTANT FOR EVERY
AMERICAN TO DO OVER THE NEXT TWO
WEEKS.
TWO SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTS THE
SPREAD OF THE CORONAVIRUS
IN THE WEEKS AND MONTHS AHEAD.
ALL OF OUR EXPERTS TELL US, AND
THEY ADVISED THE PRESIDENT AS HE
ENDORSED OF THESE GUIDELINES, TO
AVOID SOCIAL GATHERINGS OF MORE
THAN TEN PEOPLE.
IF YOU ARE SICK, STAY HOME.
IF THERE IS SOMEONE IN YOUR HOME
THAT CONTRACTS THE CORONAVIRUS,
THAT EVERYONE SHOULD STAY HOME.
ALL THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
PARKED IN PARCEL OF AN EFFORT BY
HER EXPERTS, ENDORSED BY THE
PRESIDENT TO LIMIT THE REACH OF
THE CORONAVIRUS OVER THE COMING
WEEKS AND MONTHS.
WE NEED EVERY AMERICAN, EVERY
AMERICAN BUSINESS TO STEP
FORWARD AND RECOGNIZE THAT IF WE
ACT NOW, IF WE ACT NOW, WE CAN
LIMIT THE SPREAD OF THE
CORONAVIRUS SIGNIFICANTLY AND
ULTIMATELY SAVE LIVES.
>> Sean: LETS GO THROUGH A
LITTLE CHECKLIST IF WE CAN.
I KNOW YOU DON’T HAVE A LOT OF
TIME.
HOW QUICKLY WILL THE DRIVE UP
TESTING SITES OF WALMART AND CVS
PARKING LOTS, ET CETERA, I WISH
I COULD NAME THEM ALL, BECAUSE
THEY HAVE REALLY STEPPED UP TO
THE PLATE.
HOW LONG DO YOU EXPECT THOSE AND
HOW BIG OF A PART OF THE COUNTRY
WILL BE COVERED?
>> WHAT IS HAPPENING IS THAT AS
OF LAST WEEK, TEN STATES AROUND
THE COUNTRY HAD INITIATED DRIVE
THROUGH TESTING CENTERS.
BUT SEAN, THEY WERE USING THE
OLD MANUAL TESTING METHODS IN
LABS, WHICH COULD ONLY TEST
ABOUT 40-60 PEOPLE A WEEK.
BECAUSE PRESIDENT TRUMP, TWO
WEEKS AGO, BROUGHT TOGETHER THE
TOP COMMERCIAL LABS IN THE
COUNTRY, AND BECAUSE THE FDA
MOVED IN RECORD TIME, NOW WE
HAVE WHAT ARE CALLED TESTS,
AUTOMATED TESTS, THAT CAN
LITERALLY TEST THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE A DAY FOR THE
CORONAVIRUS.
I COULDN’T BE MORE PROUD.
THE DEDICATED PEOPLE AT U.S.
PUBLIC HEALTH SERVICE AND FEMA
ARE WORKING WITH STATES AROUND
THE COUNTRY TO BUILD ON THE
STATE’S EFFORTS TO ESTABLISH
DRIVE-THROUGH AND COMMUNITY
CORONAVIRUS TESTING CENTERS.
THOSE ARE COMING ONLINE STARTING
TOMORROW AND THEY WILL BE
WIDENING THEIR SCOPE AROUND THE
COUNTRY.
WE ARE GOING TO BE SUPPORTING
STATE EFFORTS.
WE WILL BE WORKING WITH THEM TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE RETAILERS,
WHICH ARE CVS AND TARGETED, AND
WALGREENS, AND WALMART, THAT
THEY ARE OPENING THEIR PARKING
LOTS WERE DRIVE-THROUGH CENTERS
ARE INCLUDED.
BUT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE CAN BE
CONFIDENT THAT NOW THAT WE HAVE
THE COMMERCIAL LABS AROUND THE
COUNTRY WITH THOSE HIGH SPEED
AUTOMATED TESTS, YOU ARE
LITERALLY GOING TO SEE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF TESTS IN THE DAYS
AND WEEKS AHEAD FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> Sean: LET’S TALK ABOUT WHAT
WE HAVE FOR MEDICAL EQUIPMENTS.
IT WAS RELEASED BY THE PENTAGON.
THAT’S REALLY GOOD NEWS IN A
WORST-CASE SCENARIO.
ALSO, TALK TO DOCTOR.
HE SAID THAT HE LIKES TO ERR ON
THE SIDE OF CAUTION.
WORST-CASE SCENARIO IS WHAT YOU
ARE PLANNING FOR.
ARE WE READY FOR THAT FOR
EXAMPLE, CITIES THAT MAY BE
OVERWHELMED WHERE WE HAVE TRIAGE
CAPABILITIES, DOCTORS ON STANDBY
WITH ALL THE EQUIPMENT THAT THEY
NEED, THE MEDICAL SUPPLIES, THE
TENTS, SUPPORTING STAFF, THAT WE
COULD SEE 1:30 CARGO PLANE THEM
OVER.
>> WELCOME SEAN, TODAY, THE
PRESIDENT CAN BE THE NATION’S
TOP INDUSTRIAL SUPPLIERS.
NAMES THAT ARE FAMILIAR.
HOME DEPOT, AMAZON, AND OTHERS.
WE DIRECTED THEM TODAY TO ENSURE
THAT THOSE CRITICAL MEDICAL
SUPPLIES ARE BEING FOCUSED AWAY
FROM CONSTRUCTION AND OTHER
INDUSTRIES AND FOCUSED
EXCLUSIVELY ON THE NEEDS OF OUR
HEALTH CARE INDUSTRY.
THE PRESIDENT HAS MADE IT CLEAR
THAT THIS IS ALL HANDS ON DECK.
WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH BUSINESSES.
CLOSELY WITH GOVERNORS.
I SPOKE TO THE GOVERNOR OF
NEW JERSEY TODAY.
WASHINGTON STATE YESTERDAY.
WE ARE DAY BY DAY EVALUATING
WHAT THEIR NEEDS ARE.
OUR PRIORITIES FOR PEOPLE THAT
HAVE CONTRACTED THE CORONAVIRUS,
MAKING SURE THAT THEY HAVE THE
TESTING AND THE CARE THAT EVERY
AMERICAN WANTS FOR THEIR FAMILY.
OUR SECOND PRIORITY, RIGHT AFTER
IT, IS OUR HEALTH CARE WORKERS,
SEAN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS MADE IT
CLEAR THAT WE ARE GOING TO USE
EVERY EFFORT OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, EVERY RESOURCE OF
THE GOVERNMENT, AS WELL AS
HARNESSING THE POWER OF THE
PRIVATE SECTOR TO MAKE SURE OUR
HEALTH CARE WORKERS HAVE THE
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
THAT THEY NEED TO DO THEIR JOB
SAFELY.
>> Sean: MR. VICE PRESIDENT, I
WANT TO ASK YOU THIS.
ESPECIALLY ON THE ECONOMY.
WE KNOW THAT THERE’S THERE ARE C
GOING OUT I BELIEVE IN THE NEXT
TWO WEEKS.
PEOPLE PAYING THEIR TAXES WILL
GET A DELAY.
NO PENALTIES, NO INTEREST.
THERE IS GOING TO BE SET UP FOR
THOSE SMALL BUSINESSES AND
RELIEF FOR WORKERS, REALLY FOR
THOSE INDUSTRIES IN PARTICULAR,
AIRLINES.
THE PRESIDENT HAS MENTIONED THE
CRUISE LINE INTERESTS.
INDUSTRY.
WE MAY BE SPENDING CLOSE TO A
TRILLION DOLLARS?
>> SEAN, WHAT THE PRESIDENT HAS
MADE CLEAR, AND EVERY AMERICAN
CAN BE CONFIDENT IS WE ARE GOING
TO DO WHATEVER IT TAKES.
ANY HOURLY WORKER IN THIS
COUNTRY WHO FEELS LIKE THEY MAY
HAVE CONTRACTED THE CORONAVIRUS
SHOULD STAY HOME.
THEY SHOULDN’T WORRY ABOUT
MISSING A PAYCHECK OR WORKING
WITH CONGRESS TO MAKE SURE THAT
PAID LEAVE IS AVAILABLE FOR
HARDWORKING AMERICANS.
MAKING SURE THAT THIS ECONOMY
GETS BACK ON ITS FEET AND
AMERICANS ARE ABLE TO WEATHER
THIS TIME IS ALSO A PRIORITY FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WE ARE TALKING WITH THE
LEADERSHIP IN BOTH PARTIES ON
CAPITOL HILL AND WE ARE VERY
CONFIDENT THAT AS CONGRESS DID
BEFORE, THE LEGISLATION THAT IS
MOVING THROUGH TODAY, PAID
FAMILY LEAVE AND COVER THE COST
OF THE CORONAVIRUS TESTS FOR
EVERY AMERICAN, WHETHER THEY
HAVE INSURANCE OR NOT, WE ARE
GOING TO BUILD ON THAT WITH AN
ECONOMIC STIMULUS PACKAGE THAT
WILL BRING US THROUGH THIS TIME.
WHEN WE ARE THROUGH THE
CORONAVIRUS, AS THE PRESIDENT
SIGHED AGAIN TODAY, WE KNOW THIS
ECONOMY WILL COME ROARING BACK,
SEAN.
WITH ALL THE FUNDAMENTALS THERE,
THE BEST THING WE COULD DO FOR
THE ECONOMY IS WHAT THE
PRESIDENT CALLED OUT EVERY
AMERICAN TO DO YESTERDAY IN THE
15 DAYS TO SLOW THE SPREAD.
THE MORE WE CAN DO, EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF US TO PREVENT THE SPREAD
IN OUR FAMILY, IN OUR COMMUNITY,
IN OUR PLACE OF WORK, THE SOONER
WE WILL BE THROUGH THIS.
IT WILL STILL BE WEEKS AND
MONTHS TO GO, BUT WE CAN LESSEN
THE IMPACT OF THE CORONAVIRUS IN
THE WEEKS AND MONTHS AHEAD AND
WE CAN SAVE LIVES.
AS THE PRESIDENT SAID, WHEN WE
DEFEAT THE CORONAVIRUS IN THE